let's bring you small breaking news the
European research group of eurosceptory
MPS has been meeting this morning and it
has decided to recommend its members
vote against the government in the
brexit vote that's going to be held in
Parliament later this is about the
Windsor framework a key part of course
of the future of Northern Ireland its
place within the UK and within the EU
also a very very important to Rishi
sunak's political career our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue joins us
again from parliament's Central Lobby
she also has the former business
secretary Jacobi smog alongside her Ali
perhaps not an enormous surprise at the
ERG have voted against this or decided
that they will
yes you're right not a big surprise they
stopped short yesterday of saying that
of saying that they would vote against
it but today we have confirmation ERG
officers will be recommending that their
members vote against Russia sunax
Windsor framework that doesn't
necessarily mean that all of its members
will do so we could see some abstentions
but let's speak to one ERG member who we
all know Jacob Reese morgue you have
already indicated that you will be
voting against
why I would be voting against because I
think the problem with the framework is
that solidifies the protocol which has
problems in it and it means the
continued application of EU law to
Northern Ireland and there's a real
problem with the um Green Lane which is
that if Northern Ireland ever uses the
break not to apply an EU law the EU
candidates discretion closed down the
Green Lane so we will already have some
constraint trade between one part of the
country and another but if we don't do
what the EU says it could be made worse
I think there are things in the Windsor
framework that are damaging to the
United Kingdom damaging to the union and
would actually make the situation worse
than the protocol do you accept that the
European research group just doesn't
really have the power that it did but
back in the brexit years I mean do you
really think you can inflict some some
damage on the premise today you
definitely don't want to damage the
Prime Minister I wanted this vote not to
be brought forward we don't actually
need this vote I I think that forcing
about before the dup had had all the
time it wanted to look through things
was a mistake I think turning this vote
on the break into a vote on the whole
framework was a mistake that had it been
just on the break itself it would have
been very easy to allow it to go through
but putting it on the whole framework
with all that detail which embeds EU law
into Northern Ireland is I think
problematic
Steve Baker former ERG chair has now
obviously Northern Ireland Minister has
basically compared Boris Johnson to a
pound shop Nigel farage by posing The
Windsor framework are you a pound shop
Nigel farage I would take that as a
great compliment I would like to be the
Woolworths of Nigel farage is
and um I mean
I mean in kind of pursuing a pure form
of brexit you're
no it's not the question of the pure
form there's the Northern Ireland Bill
protocol bill before the House of Lords
that should be proceeded with if
necessary the parliament act should be
used to get it through because that
solves the problem under our own law
under our own power in accordance with
the treaties and international law and
that solution's already there so I don't
understand why the government has put a
better solution to one side do you
expect there will be some abstentions
within the ERG do you think the group
will move as a block oh I I would expect
that the group will vote the way
individuals want to that this is an
indication it's not a strong whipping
organization I think a number of people
will abstain I imagine the whips are
being generous with slips to encourage
people who aren't entirely happy with it
to be away the government will win the
vote comfortably because the labor party
is on side and that's very interesting
because leopard's always been weak on
brexit has never wanted a proper brexit
uh Kirsten always wanted a second
referendum did everything he could to
stop it so once you see the labor party
supporting it you have to wonder if it's
as good as it's cracked up to be okay
Jacob risma former business secretary
thank you so much speaking to us and as
he was saying the premise is not going
to have any problems getting this
through we know that labor Vindicated
they will be voting with the Windsor
framework but the devil will be in the
detail and the numbers today is this a
conservative Rebellion that the Prime
Minister will be able to contain or will
we see a big chunk of the conservative
party of course including big names like
Boris Johnson and Liz truss voting
against him that potentially could be
very dangerous